congressional leaders confirm tonight's
baseball game we'll go ahead it's a
well-known Washington tradition that
brings Republicans and Democrats
together President Trump called for
greater unity after the shooting we may
have our differences but we do well in
times like these to remember that
everyone who serves in our nation's
capitol is here because above all they
love our country House Speaker Paul Ryan
repeated that theme when he spoke to
members yesterday Nancy Cordes is at
Nationals Park in Washington that's the
site of tonight's big game Nancy good
morning good morning Gail and there was
really no serious talk about canceling
this game in fact when congressional
leaders announced it would take place as
scheduled members of Congress erupted in
applause and no one wants it to go
forward more than the members who came
under fire we're not gonna let incidents
like this change our way of life for our
daily routines the Republican and
Democratic team managers said the game
will go on even though a couple players
are now on the injured reserve list if
you're not sure which one I'll be I'll
be the one coach and third on crutches
Roger Williams of Texas injured his
ankle diving for cover this is a game
that's been going on for over a hundred
years it goes to charity and we need to
play this baseball game general is
recognized House Speaker Paul Ryan
summoned his colleagues to the floor
Wednesday for a message of unity we are
united in our shock we are united in our
anguish an attack on one of us is an
attack on all of us
Democratic Leader Nancy Pelosi did the
same my prayer is that we can resolve
our differences in a way that furthers
the preamble to the Constitution takes
us closer to e pluribus unum it's an
injury in the family for the staff and
for our colleague and for his leadership
even with a visible increase in security
lawmakers are on edge particularly those
who were at the scene I was up to that
when this shooting started I heard a
loud noise I was about ten feet from at
mica he was really shot bad most members
have no protective detail once they
leave Capitol grounds
New York Republican Claudia Tenny
received this disturbing email one down
216 to go a shaken Chuck Fleischman
Republican of Tennessee said the
privilege to serve is worth the risk we
represent
very people every day in this country
on both sides to the island in a show of
solidarity the Democratic players
invited the Republican players out to
dinner last night but both sides say
tonight they will be all business this
is a longtime rivalry charlie and
nobody's going easy on anybody Nancy
thanks